let's talk about
this uh will smith thing so
let me grab the clip here um
watch the uncensored number one on
trending on youtube hey how about that
number one on trending i'm not surprised
eh
people just love the red meat
red meat
all right so
let me get some volume here
it's a minute 23.
um before i hit the play on this um
i'm sure most of you guys know what this
is i'm i'm really just going to be
adding some uh
thoughts on it
i mean
dude's hurting dude is
like he's hurting he uh
that slap was meant for
jada pinkett or august or a combination
of both he's he's still pissed off i
mean he shouldn't have done that
uh chris rock took it in stride he um
you know chris rock can take a slap but
will smith can't take a joke in fact
it's kind of funny you're going to see
in a sec
will smith was laughing
at the joke when rock told it and then i
think they the camera cut away you'll
see in a second
uh that's when he must have got a stern
look from jada and then he went up to uh
the stage to have uh have his little uh
download with him over here so let's
let's hit play on this and see what we
got i'm gonna have to speed this up and
and pause it at least once just for uh
you know issues with uh infringements
and blah blah blah but here we go you
know who's got the hardest job tonight
javier baldem and his wife are both
nominated now if she loses he can't win
i don't even know
javier guy anyway so this is the joke on
um
cheetah pinkett she's got a um a
condition i think it's alopecia or
something like that either way she's
losing
more hair than what she should so she's
just shaving her head uh i guess it
happens to women it's not it's not male
pattern baldness it's a different kind
of hair loss but uh she's been shaving
her head so he made a joke about gi jane
which is um i don't know if it's a new
movie coming up but
uh who was in the first one demi moore
was in the first one and she had to
shave her head for it and plants like
please lord
jaina i love you gi jane too can't wait
to see it all right
okay
jada pinkett smith has a very unhappy
look on her face
will smith let's just slow this down
is laughing his ass off check this
little segment out
look he's laughing she ain't happy
now the camera cuts from here
and the next thing you see is smith
walking up on stage
it's jealous that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
now some people have said oh that's fake
it was stage they're not getting enough
views so they had to
manufacture this drama to get more views
on it and
look
um
maybe you believe it maybe you don't
this looks real enough to me i mean
will smith's been hurting did you guys
see the entanglement video if you
haven't seen it
you can look it up on youtube it's out
there there's a video of uh will and
jada sitting at i think a red table
and she's basically talking about an
entanglement which uh ended up her
essentially banging their son's friend
august
um i don't know what the age difference
was but he's quite a bit younger
obviously than will smith
and uh she spent some time with him
there's some public photographs of her
and august
at some events
um
she's she's a garden tool you know she's
a 304 you can call her whatever you know
it is but uh
dude should have left her then
that slap wasn't meant for chris rock
i'm sure that they're boys i'm sure
they've had some good times together but
the fact that it happened publicly
and they're it looks like they're
sitting in the front row and jada had
that disturbed look on her face
uh when will was done laughing at the
joke obviously that's when he came up on
stage and uh did this
wow
he walks off the stage with some swagger
i mean
it's kind of funny but anyway
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
okay so now
to add insult to injury not only can
will smith not keep his cool but now he
starts yelling at rock
across
the stage telling him well
you can hear it it's you know it's loud
enough that the mic picks it up
wow dude yeah it was a g.i james keep my
fights name out your [ __ ] mouth i'm
that's a beta
dude like
he plays alpha roles in films and movies
um but in real life dude is as plugged
in as they come he is
he's not in a good place like
dude needs something i'm going to okay
you should have got rid of that woman no
i could oh okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
okay
so anyway that's um
that's what went down it's uh
you know the whole drama thing around it
now i want to talk about this uh male
birth control situation in a moment
i've got my
pages up over here we're good to go
let's see what's going on here in the
chat uh mop saying yeah he's so hurt
uh here let me change the banner that's
not popping up where i want it to be i
think we want classic style there we go
that's better okay so
uh never split the difference from chris
voss how much is gold and how much is
blue pill i'm not sure what that has to
do with the cast we're talking about
here
complete b move by will smith yeah like
like i said that wasn't intended for
chris rock that slap was intended for a
combination of august and jada
um
he can't he can't do it though so he
takes it out on his boy rock it's
typically what ends up happening you
know
um i've seen lots of photographs and
videos over the years of will smith and
chris rock hanging out so it's not like
they don't know each other well
they do it's just he you know if you
can't control your emotions you know um
life lesson you got to learn guys if you
cannot control your emotions and
adversarial type of conditions or in
environments especially at something
like an oscars award
in front of the entire like the world is
watching
the world is watching and he thought it
was a good idea to walk up there and
[ __ ] slap the [ __ ] out of chris rock
dude took it
anyway that's what happens when you're
hurting man guys do irrational things um
yeah i mean
hey will smith you need help
give me a call bro i'll you know hook
you up i'll straighten you out i'll plug
your ass from the stupid lies that you
believe in life why why you're still
dealing with that woman is beyond me man
don't know hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you